c'est non non je voudrais juste revenir
sur un petit truc vous êtes alors je les
prendrais tout à l'heure parce que nous
restions dans le domaine du théâtre vous
avez quelle infection acide pour le
moins sur les restaurants du coeur ces
manifestations générales qui mobilise
beaucoup de genres et du show business
et de la télévision et du cinéma enfin
un petit peu partout ça vous ça vous
plaît pas ça non je trouve je pèse mes
mots je trouve qu'il est une obscénité
montrer sa charité à tous les passants
comme on montre son cul je veux dire
qu'on peut très bien faire le bien
autour de soi moi je bouge je me mets
pas en avant du tout dans un même
restaurant parce que je suis content
mais j'ai mes pauvres et je les montre
pas tous les passants j'ai vu de ces
démissions sur des restaurants du coeur
où il y avait oui mais c'était très joli
d'ailleurs mai
il y avait un producteur de disques a
ramassé des maquettes pas lui d'ailleurs
et qui en a qui les a bidouillé triturer
et qui a mis les applaudissements bidon
pour faire un disque et puis qui a
profité de cette émission sur les
affamés pour vendre son disent que ce je
ne sais pas si c'est humainement très
jolie voix ya d'autres gens il ya des
chanteurs coup dans cette émission qui
sont venus qui n'ont pas la chance de se
montrer ailleurs dans d'autres émissions
de télévision parce qu'on leur demande
pas qui sont venus donner leur but
droits d'auteur tout ça il ya un peu bas
pas très joli
j'aimerais mais ce que vous croyez que
c'est quand même pas c'est comme
toujours sa part quand même d'un bon
fond même si à ham et wigan à l'oeuf est
de mobiliser une population qui sinon
serait quand même assez passive mais ça
devrait chauffer de mobiliser des gens
par la télé mais oui mais c'est quand
même arrivé à faire quelque chose c'est
bien les gens devraient se mobiliser eux
mêmes ce qui est un peu utopiste ou
alors c'est pour lui c'est de couvrir
implique de le faire les cas prendre moi
je suis prêt à donner sur mes impôts
seront voudra pour que les gens crèvent
pas de faim
ouais mais là je pense que tout le monde
criera à l'atteinte aux libertés alors
que là ne donne pas ce qu'ils veulent si
on atteignait pour liberty redorer pas
d'autoroute on aurait pas de machine à
vapeur on n'aurait même pas de bombe
atomique en savane dans la merde ouais
ouais c'est pas d'impôts surtout en ce
qui concerne autoroute remarquer oui
enfin je sais pas j'étais pas tout à
fait c'est pour ça que je voulais mais
il ya plein de choses
d'accord moi je moi je ressemble j'aime
bien me sentir tout ça mais j'ai un goût
du paradoxe je rajoute un peu la donne
puisque plaisir mais je pense quand même
je pense je dis je trouve pas joli de
montrer son nez moudre et mais là
j'aimerais une solution alors dans ce
genre de problème là pas forcément pour
les restaurants du coeur mais est-ce que
vous quand vous êtes contre un truc
comme ça qui vous visiblement vous mais
je pense qu'on devrait civiquement et
éduquer les gens et à commencer par les
mômes
on a ce que je sais c'est pas du rêve et
sait pas à quel titre à quel titre un
clown comme moi peut dire moi je vais
donner un cachet fait que moi je pense
en quoi je suis habilité
je préfère ce genre de démarche que que
le quinqua leaders d'opinion comme peut
être un comédien ou un chanteur qui dit
moi je vote comme ça va être comme ça je
préfère l'autre déception
ça me gêne autant qu'un jeune moins
qu'un clown aucun acteur disent je vote
comme ça fait fait que moi en plus on se
bourre regarder yves montand qui
prêchait pour staline ya 15 ans ou 20
ans maintenant il prêche contre et ça
fera très bien ce qu'ils font ces gens
là sont jamais adultes politique mental
assez conséquent de la femme les gens je
veux dire que c'est pas notre métier oui
oui c'est mais oui mais c'est bien de
donner à bouffer des pas des gens encore
ce serait mieux de leur apprendre dit un
proverbe chinois qui dit qu'il vaut
mieux apprendre à pêcher aux gens qui
est de leur donner les poissons et sa
fille ça ça enlève encore de l'état
ouais mais c'est long c'est long mais à
une part je vais pas vous dire que je
suis vraiment contre les restaurants du
coeur mais j'avais une idée le dur
c'était d'aller par le week-end avec des
copains cambrioler les restaurants du
coeur pour me faire une réserve de
petits pois mais là je ne ferai pas
c'est pourquoi le mauvais goût oui c'est
ça je vous le confirme et oui et non
[Musique]